Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking it.
I'm a cybernetic organism living this yoga.
This episode is brought to you by varidesk and it actually standing at my own
varidesk right now recording this,
you've probably heard of research that shows how sitting all day is terrible for
your health.
Sitting is the new smoking,
et Cetera,
but standing all day isn't necessarily the answer for everyone.
Sometimes you just want to sit down and that's true for me as well.
The middle ground is varidesk,
varidesks height,
adjustable standing desk solutions allow you to stand when you want to sit,
when you need to,
and as an example,
I had this set to the lower position.
This is a large model and it took me clickety clack two seconds to raise this
thing up and it feels like it has hydraulics effectively because they didn't
have to use any muscle to do at varidesk converts your existing desk.
For instance,
if you want to get a tabletop version,
which you can put on it,
which is very,
very cool or cubicle into a sit stand workstation and allows you to raise your
desk from a seated to standing position in just seconds,
ships fully assembled so there's no Allen wrenches screwdrivers required,
pull it out of the box,
put it on your desk.
In the case of this particular model,
no installation or fascinating required,
there are bunch of different options.
Model,
start at just $175 so check out [inaudible] dot com to see what model might be
the right fit for you.
And my assistant now has one,
I have one.
We've really,
really been very happy with it.
So if you're not sure if it's right for you,
that's fine.
They have a 30 day risk free guarantee which lets you try it in your own home or
office and if you decided still not for you,
you want to get rid of it,
they arrange to pick it up,
no hassle.
So check it out.
varidesk.com that's v a r I desk.com
this episode is brought to you by Wealthfront.
Wealthfront is the future of financial advice.
They become incredibly popular among my friends in silicon valley and across the
country because they provide the same high end financial advice that the best
private wealth managers deliver it to the ultra wealthy,
but for any account size and at a fraction of the cost.
For instance,
they monitor your portfolio every day across more than a dozen asset classes to
look for opportunities to rebalance or harvest tax losses.
Now,
would you do the same?
Are you doing the same?
Probably not.
And the powers and the software wealth front now manages more than $4 billion in
assets,
which is up from around 2.5 billion.
When they started advertising on this podcast,
they're growing incredibly quickly.
Unlike old fashioned private wealth managers.
Wealth front is powered by innovative technology,
making it the most tax efficient,
low cost,
hassle free way to invest.
They don't have bloated sales teams or retail locations so they can deliver all
of this sophisticated financial advice and the services at fraction of the cost
of a traditional financial advisor.
So at the very least,
go to wealthfront.com forward slash Tim and take their free risk assessment
survey.
It only takes a couple of minutes and Wealthfront.
We'll recommend a personalized portfolio of investments.
In other words,
they'll tell you exactly where they would put your money,
so even if you don't use their service,
you have a huge leg up and you have additional information for making good
decisions.
They use investment theory to automate good financial behavior and decisions
that people typically don't make,
but should so go to wealthfront.com forward slash Tim to get your first 15 k
managed for free or just to get more details,
check out wealthfront.com forward slash Tim.
Hello boys and girls.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
it is my job to dig around,
find world class performers of all sorts of stripes and breeds and species and
deconstruct what they do.
How do they make decisions?
What do they do first thing in the morning?
What are the habits,
routines,
details that you can apply to your life?
And this particular episode was very much an in demand requested episode and the
guest is Mr. Money mustache at Mr. Money mustache,
Pete aid knee in real life.
He grew up in Canada in a family of mostly eccentric musicians,
then graduated from computer engineering in the 1990s and worked in various tech
companies before retiring at age 30 peed his wife and they're now 11 year old
son live near Boulder,
Colorado and they've not had real jobs since 2005 this begs the question of
course,
how,
how did they do that?
They accomplished this early retirement by doing a number of things,
but in effect optimizing all aspects of their lifestyle for maximal fund at
minimal expense.
And by using basic index fund investing,
their annual expenses on average total a mere 25,000 to $27,000 and they do not
feel in want of anything.
So again,
since 2005 all three of them have explored a freeform life of interesting
projects,
side businesses and adventures.
In 2011,
Pete started writing the Mr Money Mustache blog about his philosophy,
which has grown to reach about 23 million different people and 300 million page
views since its inception.
Since its founding,
it has become a worldwide cult phenomenon with a self organizing community and
incredible news coverage.
This episode explores his story,
philosophies and routine.
So without further ado,
please enjoy my conversation with the one and only Mr. Money Mustache Pete
[inaudible].
Pete,
welcome to the show.
Thanks Tim.
Edson arms to be on here and you are,
I would say in the top five most requested guests for this podcast
that,
uh,
that I see on the Internet and beyond.
I had somebody come up to me recently in New York City of all places.
He said,
you know,
you should have on the podcast and it was you.
And so I'm
really excited to dig into all sorts of stories and conversations and
discussions because I'm thinking through many areas of my life in which I think
you are an expert or have certainly spent more time ruminating on these things.
But I thought we could start with your experience getting groceries.
Could you describe for people what your experience looks like getting groceries?
Uh,
well it's kind of varied,
but I feel strongly about groceries.
So in an ideal,
like a Utopian Grocery Day,
I would throw my bike trailer onto the back of my single speed bike and roll
down to like the local kind of hippie natural grocery store,
and then just load up with like 150 bucks of awesome stuff and then pedal it
back up the hill and then unload it and then have people show up and the giant
barbecue that night and a feast.
So if that's the utopia,
what does the,
what does the compromised utopia look like?
Well,
it's usually pretty close to that,
but sometimes people don't come over or sometimes,
uh,
there's some reason I have to use the car and maybe I'm taking,
taking it past the grocery store so our Russian and get some stuff.
But I think the,
you know,
the thrust of the question is like,
does this guy really uh,
get groceries about bicycle?
And it's definitely true.
I'd kind of do everything by bike here in Longmont,
Colorado or like at least 99% of my trips,
uh,
away from the house here are human powered.
And that's just the way I've figured out.
Makes me happiest to live
at this point in time.
You have a household of three,
is that right?
Yeah,
that's true.
One boy,
one boy,
one girl and got it.
All right.
And,
and what,
uh,
what is the cause I think this is,
this is a,
this is going to be a core piece of the discussion.
What are your average annual family expenses at this point would you say?
All right,
well we've been adding this up ever since I started writing a blog.
We never really added it up before,
but it always comes out around 25 to $27,000 of annual expenditures,
uh,
with the notable exception that we don't have any kind of mortgage or debt or
anything.
So that's all on purely stuff that we want to buy.
And maybe we'll,
we'll,
this is going to be memento style in terms of chronology is a lot of my
conversations are as just a quirk of my brain that I'm trying to a bug.
I'm trying to turn,
turn into a feature of this podcast.
What was the blog post or the day that you realize Mr money mustache had a cult
like following?
Was there a nice use that I use that in a complimentary way,
by the way.
Uh,
you
have some of the most die hard fans I've ever encountered.
A,
was there a particular peace or moment when you realized how strongly and have
devoted your fan base was?
I think it's Kinda been like one of those frog in hot water situations where it
just gradually happens.
And then occasionally,
especially when my friends stopping on Elica money mustache event,
they're like,
dude,
you're a cult leader.
Did you realize that?
But it didn't really happen any specific time.
I would say the first time I was really surprised by the effects of blogging
with when I had a guest post on this awesome previous a blog called early
retirement extreme and a whole bunch of this,
uh,
Jacob bloggers fans came over to mine,
I blog and just flooded it and just crawled and read every single article and
started putting it on these comments.
And then I,
it was really a rewarding thing and I just kept going from there.
It's sort of a self motivating thing.
Um,
and then the other incident was probably we had a party once,
a blog related meetup in the,
in Ottawa,
Canada,
which is kind of one of my homeland hometowns.
And uh,
all these people came and like 200 people.
And it overflowed into the backyard of this like unweighting hosts place.
And a,
it was a little weird cause I didn't even get to meet anybody.
And that was the first time I became uncomfortable with like,
oh,
well I didn't want to be one of those people where you don't even meet everybody
who wants.
Nice to meet you.
Ottawa,
I've actually spent a decent amount of time in Ottawa,
uh,
and of,
and I had a beaver tail for the first time while ice skating or planning on ice
skating in Ottawa due to start up there.
Well,
it's a quite a large company now called Shopify.
Oh yeah,
I knew that.
Yeah.
And the beaver tail,
that's the right way to do Ottawa is skating.
And
you were tales.
I know beaver tail is,
I don't even remember exactly what it is,
but it's a pastry,
right?
I mean,
it's a,
what is it exactly?
It's like a chocolate covered pastry.
Uh,
and for those people who have not been to Ottawa,
you can,
you can skate for hours.
I mean,
it's this,
this gigantic,
uh,
they,
I guess they lower the water level or maybe they're raised the water level so
that you can skate effectively around the entire city,
if I,
from remembering correctly.
Yeah,
that's right.
And it's pretty awesome.
The uh,
okay.
The,
but to get back to the blog,
what,
what do you think has,
what are the aspects of your philosophy or your writing or your persona that
have struck such a chord?
Well,
it's funny you should ask that because the first time I ever did a talk,
like a big public talk,
it was a to a conference of bloggers.
It's called fin con.
And I just stopped by it because it was in Denver.
And,
uh,
I had realized that this blog was kind of behaving like a cult.
And then I looked up like,
what are the properties of a cult?
And then I read some articles and maybe a book or two on cults and I realized,
man,
I've accidentally done it.
And uh,
and just because that's my idea of a sense.
Humor is a,
so it turns out if you want to start a cult,
you need to just have a few key elements,
like a recognizable leader need to have a sense of us versus them.
You know,
like,
oh,
we're an oppressed people and the rest of the world doesn't understand us.
And a couple other things that helps to feel like you're a virtuous and have
some kind of like good changing the world and the rest of the world needs your
help.
And uh,
yeah.
So if you look at all the cults,
including informal ones like star trek or a apple,
there's always these same kind of characteristics and I accidentally emulated
those and in retrospect realized,
Hey,
well I guess that was a pretty good idea.
So for those who are part of the US,
in your case,
what is,
what's the belief system?
What are the tenets?
Right?
So the belief system,
which I jokingly call Mustachio aneurysm,
it's kind of like a lifestyle and a fake religion.
And the beliefs are that the,
you know,
sort of the unit,
the United States,
especially as the ground zero of this consumer insanity that has overtaken all
of our minds and it's just causing people to behave in an irrational way and
sort of sabotage their own ability to have a good life,
for example.
They work way more years than they have to because they're consuming a lot more
crap than they have to without actually getting any life benefit about it over.
And then the same thing applies to the health,
their health and their,
their sanity and their mental mental health there.
Everyone's very inefficiently going about their lives.
So the correction,
uh,
through mustache as him as just being a bit more thoughtful about this stuff and
seeking efficiency in the way that you spend your money and make sure that you
get fun out of it.
Each time that you spend something and,
uh,
applying this,
you just end up a lot healthier and wealthier and able to retire from mandatory
work at a much earlier age in your life,
which a lot of people are drawn in by the prospect of an extra four decades of
freedom that they wouldn't have otherwise gotten.
Correct me if I'm wrong here,
be you retired effectively at age 30,
is that right?
Right.
Yeah.
This is perfect.
Reverse chronology,
just like you've planned it.
So,
yeah,
now we're back to the year 2005 and after working about a 10 year career in
software engineering,
my girlfriend,
who's now my wife and I determined that we had enough money saved up to live off
the investment returns forever.
So we just quit our regular cubicle jobs and just in time to have our baby boy
at the time.
And that was of course about 11 years ago,
and we didn't even know this was a weird thing to do.
We thought,
oh yeah,
well of course,
you know,
when you get paid as much as we do,
like it only takes so long until you don't need to work anymore.
And it was only after several years of retirement that we noticed that we were
kind of odd balls and everybody else,
uh,
who earn the same amount of money was still broke,
broken in probably more way than one.
Uh,
in,
uh,
want to dig into some of the,
the numbers related to this.
So as a discussion
point,
one of the,
one of the things you,
you had sent over,
and I always ask guests for potential prompt for for four topics,
it could be fun to explore and one of them was you only need,
you accumulate 25 times your annual spending to retire forever.
Could you elaborate on that and how,
uh,
how you arrived at that number?
Because I think this is,
this is a useful exercise for people to hear.
Yeah.
This is a core piece of math is very,
uh,
it's widely known if you're a financial independence enthusiast,
but it's almost a completely secret to most of the,
of the rich world's population.
So if you have a,
if you have a handle on your annual spending and you know how much you need to
live on,
all you need to do is save up 25 times that amount.
And on the very,
very conservative side,
let's say 28 times that amount,
uh,
in conservative investments,
like a giant vanguard index fund.
And that's enough to fund you with passive income with a high degree of safety
for the rest of your life.
So if you have a,
to just keep the numbers simple,
if you need to $30,000 to live on,
multiply that by 25.
And I don't know,
I'm giving myself a tricky math question.
I think,
you know,
it's like $750,000 you'd need saved up or something like that to quit forever.
And that's a lot less than most people think.
Most people,
at least in my age group,
they're shooting for the tens of millions,
uh,
type of range.
If they,
if they were to ever quit work early and they haven't really done the math on
how easy it really is.
And what,
are there any assumptions embedded in that in terms of percentage,
annual yield and so on?
What are,
what are the,
uh,
whether historically based or otherwise,
what are,
what are the,
are there any other assumptions embedded in that?
It is,
yeah,
there's um,
it's kind of based on a really long term study of the stock market dating back
to the 1920s or something like that.
Or maybe even earlier.
And the idea is it goes up some years,
it goes down.
Some years consistently pays dividends
and in the worst case scenario,
you want to still not run out of money.
So that's where the 4% comes from.
We've gotten you through a lot of the worst case scenarios.
There is some situations when you could have spent up to five or 7% of your
portfolio every year and still not run out if you would happen to retired just
before a big stock market boom,
that went on for a long time.
But most people don't like taking a huge amount of risks.
So the 4% or 3.5 if you want to be extra conservative with today's stock market
valuations,
that's more of a safety net.
And it's really just a mental crutch because what I find is that when people
retire early,
almost everybody,
like over 95% of people still have a lot of interests and passions and then
they're pretty good at making money if they managed to save up that much in the
first place.
So they still make money in their retirement,
they just have a lot more fun doing it.
And,
uh,
nest egg that's pumping out dividends and returns just adds extra confidence so
they can,
they can have more fun in the process.
Well,
I've,
I've read two different definitions of retirement or maybe they're
characteristics that are,
I think one was attributed to one was written by you,
both of which I thought were very helpful as a orientation for thinking about
the subject.
Andy.
The first is you know,
retirement or financial independence simply means that you have your living
expenses covered by non work income,
right?
Part One,
part two is definition of a modern retirement,
the activities you pursue once you were done searching for money.
And,
and uh,
I think that's a very useful framework.
If in particular you're considering an early retirement,
uh,
at at say the age of 30,
40,
50,
whatever it might be.
Um,
the,
how do let's say,
media not to cast aspersions on everyone who is part of the media since I
suppose that's what I am right now at this moment.
But w you've been covered a fair amount.
And I know like everyone who's been covered a fair amount,
you get misquoted or people get the message wrong or they just take snack
Starkey cheap shots.
Uh,
occasionally it doesn't happen all the time.
You've actually had some of the most complimentary profiles I've ever read.
But where did they get it wrong?
Where do people get you your message,
your principles,
philosophies wrong?
Well,
the,
the misconceptions are sort of two different things from the media side.
They often
assume,
well,
I mean,
the ones that aren't complimentary,
they assume,
hey,
there's this crazy guy and he's just a lifestyle guru.
Just like another junior Tim Ferriss trying to get everybody excited about his
crazy ideas and he's not really retired or,
or they say,
yeah,
he,
he made so much money.
But that doesn't apply to the regular person when they're,
you know,
when they're trying to make it on like $50,000 a year salary or what about
people with more kids?
So,
um,
the media don't understand that.
They often assume some kind of extreme frugality that would be undesirable to
live under.
And,
uh,
that's,
that's really inaccurate.
And I worked pretty hard to fight it because I don't have my spending set up for
the minimal level.
I have it set up for the maximum amount that I can possibly spend and get value
out of it,
you know,
cause it's easy to make money.
So I set my spending at the maximum happiness level and then stopped spending
when I stopped getting more happiness.
So that's the,
that's really the fundamental mistake.
And then as for the non media world,
there are a little bit more suspicious.
Like they just think I'm make everything making everything up and I don't even,
you know,
I never did any of this stuff that I say I did in the first place.
So then it's more of a conspiracy theory if you're reading like the comment
section of which
you should never do,
but you do have a it,
and I think this is why this is part of,
there's no one to bring it up very early,
a by most standards in the United States,
a low household annual expense.
Right,
right.
And,
uh,
it might be helpful here to talk about because I,
I asked during our sound check what you had for breakfast,
so could you repeat your answer please?
Oh yeah.
Well,
my,
my breakfast was a fancy black espresso with milk and coconut,
coconut oil phone into there too.
And then some dark chocolate,
like 90% dark chocolate and a,
some nuts,
almonds and cashews and stuff.
And uh,
it's not exactly related to a low expenditure,
but it's indirectly related.
I'm going to,
I'm going to come back to it.
What type of,
since I love the particulars.
What type of coffee,
what type of chocolate do you recall?
Oh yeah.
Well,
right now my coffee coffee has some kind of organic fair trade thing,
but by in large quantity from Costco,
which is obviously a lot cheaper than getting a,
like a Starbucks equivalent every morning.
And a,
yeah,
the nuts are from Costco as well.
Now that you mentioned it,
this is the,
the,
the reason I bring it up is that,
uh,
and I think stumbling on happiness or stumbling on happiness by Daniel Gilbert
is,
is good exploration of this.
Oftentimes what we think will make us happy does not make us happy.
And we can talk,
we should dig into what happiness is for you,
because I think it's,
it's,
it can be a dangerously nebulous term,
but the point being that too,
to have a functional car and then to have what society tells you is the optimal
car.
Say some type of sports car,
there's a massive delta in price and you pay some severe penalties for that.
But to have a eight to go from a good chocolate to an excellent chocolate to
world class chocolate,
it might only be the difference of 10 or $12.
Right?
And so there,
there are there places where you can optimize without being obnoxiously or
frugal or frugal in indis disabling extent and derive maximum pleasure.
That's the point I was trying to make is that,
and what I would love to hear from you is for those people out there who are
spending far more multiples,
more than you are per year,
who don't know where to start,
are there any easy optimizations that could have a dramatic impact on their
ability to get closer to uh,
optimizing for happiness as opposed to,
uh,
succumbing to internal or external pressures to remain on this treadmill of,
of overconsumption.
Yeah,
right.
And this might actually be a better answer for you earlier question too,
because as a,
an engineer like I
was kind of born part engineer at least.
And for me optimization is really,
really fun.
It's like beautiful.
And when something is not optimized and when something's and efficient,
I actually find it offensive and ugly.
So I had a lot of joy.
I get a lot of joy from looking at each of my life spending decisions and being
comparing it like,
okay,
if I get this car I'd probably make me about this happy and this car would make
me this mount happy.
Whereas if I ride my bike,
it does this other thing.
And you do,
you apply that to food and housing and transportation and clothing,
travel,
exercise,
and then all these categories can become super efficient where you end up
getting incredible happiness out of them.
Uh,
and the cost can sometimes be not only low,
but sometimes you'll get paid for doing stuff that other people spend tens of
thousands of dollars to do.
So if you're a beginner at this sport of optimization,
you can just start with the stuff that costs you a lot of money.
So my favorite one to be a bit repetitive is the car,
because a,
the average middle income Americans spends like $12,000 per household,
which is just on driving around in these like gas powered racing wheelchairs.
And that's more than they even invest in,
in their future.
Like that's more than they're spending on the freedom.
So step one,
don't have a car that's worth more than about 10,000 bucks at the most.
Um,
and last year at least like a single millionaire,
preferably multimillionaire,
because you can get a great,
perfectly great car.
That'd be trouble free for 10 plus years for under $5,000 so the reasonable
ceiling would be 10 and that's already going to be a pretty giant thing for
people.
And then number two is don't use that car a lot.
So everybody assumes that you know,
a short drive to work is anything under an hour.
Whereas I think I encourage people to take a really,
really hard line approach on that because it's a giant factor in life,
happiness and fitness and money in my rule is you should never get a job.
You know,
unless you're at gunpoint,
that requires you to drive to it.
Like either find a new job,
find a place to live near that job.
I mean even if it requires moving to a new city or a new country in the long
run,
you just got to keep that nagging thing in your mind like,
okay,
I drive to work now,
but this is not optimal in the long run.
I will optimize a way car dependence and a,
yeah,
just start with that one and then you can move on.
You can read stuff on my blog and figured out how to cut your grocery costs down
and your housing and everything like that too.
But I really liked the mobility because there's fitness involved too,
you know,
and there's,
there's happiness of forcing yourself out into the fresh air every morning.
As soon as you,
you give up the cage of the car.
It's such a huge thing and it's such an overlooked thing in our country.
I deck couldn't agree more.
And I think the,
uh,
the,
it forces you to make other decisions like you pointed out.
I haven't had a car for
close to three,
I want to say.
Now,
that does not mean I don't spend time in cars.
I do,
uh,
so I,
I tend to use,
whether it's a get around for trips to Tahoe or things that are further away
that requires some travel or Uber,
but I probably walk,
walk.
I tend to walk more than I bike,
um,
for whatever reason.
But that's,
that's typically I'd say 70 80% of my locomotion as soon as great walking.
And it's,
it's helped me to make other decisions to optimize for say,
having people come to me as opposed to having to constantly bounce around a city
or travel around the environments and think about how I can better use the
capital.
I have four,
uh,
types of leverage that don't require or replace the need for bouncing around
continuously and wasting that time and transit and also found from me at least
very slow or very fast in terms of transportation work.
Well,
it's in the middle that I get very frustrated because if it's very slow,
I can also say batch phone calls,
I can listen to podcasts,
listen to audio books,
I can take time,
uh,
for that type of enrichment in the process of moving from point a to point B.
So true walking is so powerful and so underrated.
Like your brain just goes into overdrive.
All of your problems sort of start to solve themselves in the background.
And for people who don't do it regularly,
like an hour a day or walking to genuinely go somewhere,
um,
they just discount it because they haven't even experienced this incredible
power.
So I'm glad we're both on that train.
I ran that shoe.
What are exactly,
what are,
uh,
what are some of the books that have,
and this could be two different lists,
but some of the books that have had the biggest impact on you or books that you
most frequently recommend to your readership.
Yeah,
I don't have the ultimate,
I'm not the ultimate book kind of sewer.
I don't spend as much,
I don't burn through as many books as some people.
So,
uh,
but in recent months,
three books that have had a pretty big impact on me that I'm about to recommend
to people,
it really depends on who you're talking to.
So if you're into changing the world for the better,
um,
one book that's spectacularly opened up my mind is this one called happy city by
an author called Charles Montgomery.
And it kind of just pulls back the curtain on how we're wasting most of our
resources and our human and money resources on building up the country into a
spectacularly inefficient asphalt jungle.
So that's for urban planning nerds and fixing the world nerds.
Um,
but for people who feel like they personally want to,
um,
they're wondering why they're such a Weirdo.
I'm a big fan of,
uh,
the book on Elon Musk by the author,
Ashlee Vance,
I think it's called the Elon Musk,
Elon Musk and that quest for a fantastic future.
That book I read and it talks about Ilan as a little kid and growing up and it's
like,
that's exactly how I was as a kid.
I thought I was the only one and it,
he has this feeling where the world is incredibly illogical and no one's
listening and he just wants to just fucking change it.
Like I'm just going to do everything myself then and I can really everything
except for the fact that he actually does it and I don't,
I can relate completely to the feeling of that book.
And finally,
a really,
really old fashioned book if someone just wants to wake themselves up and start
turning into more of like a positive,
um,
less depressed person is this 1950s classic called the magic of thinking big.
I've recommended that to like so many friends because I stumbled across it when
I was like 15 years old and it was really,
really old even then.
And uh,
it's like this,
uh,
1950 is cheesy,
stereotypical like man's world has some flaws in that way,
but that just makes it more funny and it's a great way to just remind yourself
like,
oh,
when you think big and act confident and sparkly,
then it's amazing how much stuff actually goes better for you.
So those are my three.
So I can't comment on the first two,
but I,
I have to comment on the magic of thinking big.
So I have a copy,
my original copy of the magic of thinking big about 15 feet to the side of me
right now in my living room.
It is one of the books that has traveled with me and its face out.
So I see it every day when I'm sitting on my couch along with a handful of
others.
Tribe from Sebastian,
younger Dune,
Frank Herbert.
That's a bit of a long story.
Gratitude,
Oliver Sacks.
I'm looking at them right now.
Bird by bird,
by Anne Lamott,
Zorba the Greek and less is more,
which is an anthology of writing on minimalism.
And,
uh,
the magic of thinking big by David Schwartz.
This book,
despite the title,
which like you said,
I mean it's,
it's,
it's screams cheesy at you.
It was why it's good though.
It is.
It's like gorgeously delightfully cheese.
And you're like,
yes,
I'm 1959 as well as you're conducting business.
No,
exactly.
And it was,
it was introduced to me by a man named Stephen [inaudible],
Stephen Key,
fascinating guy.
He lives in,
I think it's Turlock,
California,
middle of nowhere,
and has built this,
this fantastic career for himself,
developing products,
a lot of toys and licensing them to gigantic companies,
whether it's Disney or Nestle,
Coke,
Cola,
you name it.
And uh,
he,
he makes these incredibly simple prototypes out of construction paper
oftentimes.
And then we'll license these ideas for,
I'm assuming hundreds of thousands,
millions of dollars over time.
And he was given the magic of thinking big at one point by,
uh,
I believe it was a fortune 500 CEO.
So the lineage hip least or the path that the book took to me was,
was fascinating in and of itself.
And I read it,
I would say around 2003,
2004 which was just before I took my,
my walkabout and did all the experiments [inaudible] with my business at the
time.
Two either redesign the business or shut it down.
And that was the journey that then precipitated the writing of the four hour
workweek.
So the,
the magic of thinking big.
I,
I've been meaning to reread it and part of me,
I don't know,
tell me if I'd be curious to get your peanuts.
So I read it so long ago and I have such a high opinion of it that I'm worried I
will read it now and it will not age well when I read it a second time.
Have you read it recently?
Uh,
last time was probably about five years ago and I've found out it's just as
good.
I just love the CRI,
the,
you know,
the overly simple examples.
Like imagine that there's two little gentlemen in your head there is Mr. Success
and Mr. Defeat Mr. Defeat always wants to throw some oil and sand and to is your
crank case of your mind and it's just like these,
you know,
I find that most,
maybe this is my engineer's brain handicap again,
but I really get annoyed by overly flowery language like kind of Harper's
magazine,
Atlantic stuff where people just go on for like eight pages to cover something
that could have fit in a couple sentences.
Right.
And Dr. Schwartz doesn't do any of that shit and that in fact his writing style,
it really inspired me.
And like when I write as Mr Money Mustache,
I'm thinking,
I'm like channeling David Jason Schwartz,
and he always starts off every story with this little anecdote.
Like that's makes them sound like casual and powerful.
He's like,
oh,
it was relaxing in my lounge one day when a few of my employees came in for
questions.
You know,
like,
you know,
you got to read it again.
I'm going to return.
All right.
It's been on my,
it's been on my to do list for January because I've set aside,
we're doing this interview in January,
2017 and I've set aside,
uh,
the first two weeks minimum to simply consider options because I've in the past,
fallen prey to over calendaring myself,
uh,
and for fun things in,
in many cases,
but nonetheless over calendaring.
So I don't have as much slack in the system,
uh,
empty space as I would like and,
I've been meaning to as part of my self imposed curriculum,
reread the magic of thinking big.
So I will,
I will jump into that.
How are you different from Mr?
Money Mustache,
if,
if at all?
Um,
well the lines are pretty fine.
Pretty,
you know,
I,
I don't know if there's like a really formal dif difference,
but,
um,
he's probably a bit more perfect than me.
Like I,
I'll complain occasionally and,
uh,
if I don't catch myself and I won't,
I don't actually complain on the blog about,
you know,
when and where I'm going to add this.
The world is being mean to me.
But in general,
like because I magic of thinking big so long ago and internalized it so much and
I kind of ran my work career and my,
you know,
my international adventures of moving to the u s and everything under those
assumptions,
I,
I feel like,
you know,
I'm pretty,
I'm failing Mr Money Mustache,
I'm more sensitive.
She,
the thing like,
I don't lecture people in real life about,
you know,
like I don't actually smash my fist through the driver window of pickup trucks
and honk the horns with their foreheads and tell them they shouldn't be going
through the drive through with a stupid off road diesel thing.
But,
but I think it,
but,
and I write it,
so yeah,
the Mr Money Mustache is a little more violent in,
uh,
in his writing and confrontational.
And I enjoy that because it helps me remain more calm in my real life because
nobody wants to be lectured in real life about.
Even if you have some ideas you want to share with them,
you have to wait for them to come to you.
And when you're running a blog,
they have come to you by definition,
which means there are a lot more open to having their faces punched in a literal
a literary sense,
right?
You get to get pros mugged,
uh,
while you're,
while you're shaping their behavior.
Uh,
the question of the u s so the,
uh,
I spent a little bit of time in China and even as a,
as an American who's somewhat desensitized to consumption,
I think that China's,
it's appears to be 10 times more materialistic and ended it driven towards over
consumption.
But the,
that's not really leading.
I don't want to lead us necessarily a new conversation about China.
The,
the ad,
the question I was going to ask,
and this may have a very simple answer,
why did you decide to stay in the u s I just love it.
Here it goes.
Uh,
it's kind of like the furnace of the world.
Like many of the problems,
uh,
in the u s that stem from under regulation are also its strengths in the sense
that you can just start stuff up and then nobody even notices that you're doing
it.
And you can have a giant company before anyone's even noticed.
And uh,
it's just the entrepreneurial and the optimism and the lack of rules is kind of,
it goes along with my personality personality because I hate rules.
Um,
I'm really in favor of people self regulating in the sense that don't be a jerk
to your neighbor and don't pollute the world and everything like that,
which is the part that annoys me about some of the u s a business culture,
but in general,
I just love it here and I love the giant range of geographies to compare it to
Canada,
which is kinda just a string of cds along the border and the u s you have a grid
of cities and islands that range from like Arctic Tundra to tropical islands and
coconut,
coconut shell tops and everything like that.
It's just a lot more variety and excitement here.
Yeah,
there is,
there is a lot of variety or,
and I've actually decided that this year will be my year of exploration in the
domestic United States.
And I've,
I've,
I've realized that my default and the default of,
of many people,
I think when they have their designated time for travel or vacation,
is oftentimes to fantasize about the trips overseas.
And I've realized I've neglected to explore so much diversity in the United
States itself.
So I'm planning on somehow transporting,
uh,
me and my pooch around the country,
which I am very excited to do.
And next thing I'd like to do is,
is read something and get your comments on it.
So this is,
uh,
this is from a,
a piece,
a profile of yours in the,
the New Yorker,
a which congratulations,
I guess it's one of the top 16.
Is it most read of the year,
uh,
profile,
something along those lines.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
I saw that.
Thanks to you.
I think on Twitter
I did,
I might've driven,
uh,
some traffic there,
which,
which uh,
I was happy to do and also hesitant to do because I know that there are,
I'm s I'm for sure there are things that are at the,
at the best incomplete,
uh,
and,
and maybe completely off base at worst,
but that's just the nature of the beast when you're dealing with these types of
profile.
Yeah.
I did a snarky responses,
a section for that,
like complete on that genius.
Start it website if anybody you're inline responsive.
Yeah.
Cause that way you can,
the writer can write his story and then I can add my stuff right on the side and
that kind of corrects for the one sidedness of
normal New Yorker journalism.
Yeah.
I might have to do that myself,
although I'm not sure I want to reopen the wound.
I was misquoted even after correcting fact checkers,
I was misquoted and number of people were misquoted properly.
Half a dozen times in the piece that I had in the New Yorker,
which really rankled me because of course it sits at the top of Google with page
rank,
but water under the bridge for now.
Uh,
I'll put that aside.
The piece I wanted to read though I don't,
I don't think is going to a,
okay,
push those buttons.
Uh,
let me start with the following.
So being an engineered,
he runs the numbers once after his bike was apparently stolen,
he ruminated on the wisdom of locking one spike.
And this is a,
this is then to your writing.
This was the first theft in many,
many years of very carefree living.
The craigslist for replacement value of that bike was probably around $500.
What value do I place on a decade of the fearless freedom of leaving shit
happily unlocked and not worrying about it?
How about the value of my time saved and not spending my life fumbling with an
enormous key chain,
90 seconds a day for 10 years and 91 hours or at least $4,500 in my time at $50
an hour.
I was still coming out way ahead and you concluded if you can't afford to lose
it,
you can't afford to buy it yet.
Otherwise the owns you rather than vice versa.
And there,
there are plenty of folks out there who,
who think we are more opposed then I think we are,
uh,
because the type of math that you did here,
and I'd love to get your thoughts on it,
but these are the types of things that I think about constantly.
Uh,
the how the in the,
how many of these rote decisions,
common decisions are burning up the nonrenewable resource of time in the
interest of some marginal utility perceived marginally utility in terms of,
of dollars and cents.
But,
uh,
I'd love to hear any sort of thoughts who are,
or elaborations that you have on this because I,
I love this example.
Yeah.
Well,
it's,
it is the math sometimes explicit like that and sometimes more implicit,
um,
that drives most of my decisions.
And that's why I'm surprised like anybody who says that Mr Money Mustache and
Tim Ferris are opposites in any kind of way.
I think they're not really understanding the picture because it's really just an
optimization process,
right?
Like,
um,
I'm not opposed to spending money.
My only limitations on spending money are number one,
it has to make me happy.
And number two,
a factor in my personal happiness is like resource consumption because I kind of
know the numbers behind all the costs to other people like into the earth or
everything that I buy.
So that kind of rules out certain types of spending that other non sciency,
non environmentalist people might feel okay about.
But if you push that bit aside,
um,
it's all just about having the maximum amount of fun.
So,
um,
and if you have limited money,
then having to go to work for a longer time is a genuine source of non-fun and
thus spending less money is going to give you more of something that's more fun,
which is time and then you're all set.
So that's a win.
And then now in this post work a world where I've stumbled into more money than
I could have.
Imagine having my spending hasn't changed and that's just a sign that I got some
of the decisions approximately right to begin with.
And,
and if I had started buying more stuff afterwards that might've been assigned
that I didn't really do the math right to begin with.
What do you do with the,
and I apologize that this is a simplistic question,
but what do you do with the money that you have as a surplus in this post work
life?
What happens to if the expenses aren't going up or nominally go up and down by a
few thousand dollars a year?
How do you allocate the surplus?
Yeah,
that's some,
that's another thing that has to be optimized.
And because I,
I feel that money is such a valuable resource,
so I'm still working on it.
So I tried,
you know,
I've,
I've been doing small donations,
like I'm paying for more
stuff when other people I know can't afford it.
And then I did a medium size donation,
uh,
with the effective under the effective altruism movement that I know that you've
covered at one point in your tools of titans book.
Yeah.
Well,
mechanical on the,
uh,
on the podcast,
the cofounder or maybe founder of,
of that movement.
Yeah.
And I think one of those two founders sent me an email after I sent my donation
to them.
And,
uh,
they seem really,
really,
really sharp people.
Uh,
so that's,
uh,
that's one useful thing to do with surplus money.
The only reason I have some of it still sitting in my investment accounts and
it's still rolling in of course,
cause they still have this unexpected blog income.
MMM.
Is I feel like I can leverage the attention of all these people for something
good.
And that would be bigger than just donating,
like,
you know,
$1 million per whatever period to um,
to standard causes.
I think.
Um,
I would,
I would like to create kind of like one of those tipping point effects in the u
s that might for example,
tip us more towards bike based transfer temporal rotation.
Um,
instead of a car based,
you know,
and,
and potentially save like billions or trillions of dollars of society's wealth
and have it go somewhere better if the whole society got more excited about a
different way of living.
So that's why I haven't just given away all the money yet because I feel like
for example,
what if I could start like a little mini town where we do things really
awesomely?
And this of course it sounds a bit like a cult.
Like,
Oh yeah,
we have to start a commune.
But uh,
yeah,
that's something also sounds like Singapore,
right?
Yeah.
Right.
Rian within a town based on the ideas of cohousing or something like that.
So these guy ideas are still swimming around in my head.
I haven't solved the problem of how to deal with a surplus money efficiently.
But once I do,
then I will started having some fun with it.
And then I'll probably also start trying to make more money and like have the
blog make more money because then I'll have a use for it.
And the,
I'd love to hear more about how you,
your decision making process or thought process or internal dialogue when you
are considering buying something,
what are the questions that you ask yourself?
And if it's related to happiness,
I want to okay.
Define that.
And maybe a way to do that is,
you know,
how do you know when you're happy or unhappy?
Uh,
but I'd love to just maybe take those in,
in either order really.
But what,
what's the,
what's the thought process like,
or the internal monologue slash dialogue when you're considering buying
something?
Yeah.
Well usually I try to start with like,
no,
you're,
we need,
what do you think?
What kind of consumer are you?
You know,
like just a little bit of mental beat down to shut off the easiest things.
That's what keeps me from buying like like a Tesla model s or something like
that.
Because even though I think it's a great car,
I support it.
I know for sure that wouldn't make me any happier cause I don't even have
anything to do with it.
Like I don't drive really.
So so obvious stuff gets shut off.
But then when you get into like things that you're pretty sure you want,
then you just think about it for longer,
procrastinate a little bit,
see if the desire goes away a bit and then consider how much space that thing is
going to take up in my,
my limited a space of my studio for example.
And then imagine how I would feel if it broke.
Cause a lot of stuff does break even if you have high quality gear and it's
really annoying to deal with things that break and if you have to warranty,
fix it.
And finally I ask myself,
is this removing a negative in my life?
Because it's pretty well studied that happiness is not very much affected by
adding positives to your life.
It's mostly,
especially in a rich world environment like we live,
it's mostly accomplished by removing things that are a strong negative to every
day.
So getting myself like a remote control photography drone is unlikely to make me
happier because my life doesn't currently sucks due to the absence of
photography,
drone quad copter thing.
He's so that's,
you know,
and whereas if there's something that every day I'm like,
damn it,
I just wished I didn't always trip over this,
you know,
broken dishwasher,
whatever that then replacing your dishwasher is,
it's probably going to be a happiness,
uh,
boosting proposition.
What's,
what purchases,
uh,
or productions for that matter?
I know you make a lot of things,
but what purchases just to stick with one category that come to mind have most
improved your happiness by removing negatives?
Yeah.
Well that's a perfect followup question because I'm talking to you right now in
this studio building that I made over the process of the last year.
It's kind of a thrifty,
like a 400 square foot modernist,
a thing with a lot of windows and,
and uh,
overlooking this nice forest did park behind my house.
So,
um,
I had a consistent problem after I moved to this current house we live in,
in 2013.
It's a bit too small for our style of living.
So I was genuinely tripping over stuff a bit and always having to move things
around.
And I had some of my equipment out in the back,
like my table saw.
I would have to live under a tarp during the rare Colorado precipitation events
and I realized,
you know,
more space would actually solve this problem.
And I always want it to have a detached studio anyway to play music in because
um,
I don't want to have to like drown out my family three years when I'm playing
bad rock music with my friends.
So I built the studio and um,
I did it all myself because I know from experience that this manual labor and
solving physical problems and one of the happiest things I can possibly do,
just like,
you know,
hundreds of hours of lifting and sweating and digging and you know,
all these amazing,
he's full outdoor things with friends.
And now I'm,
I'm in,
you know,
um,
recording a Tim Ferris podcast in my studio,
surrounded my drums and bass and guitar and watching the trees sway outside.
So this has been really a genuine happiness boosting spendage expenditure of
money and it's brought me happiness pretty much from the day I broke ground on
this,
you know,
this piece of dirt.
So,
so no regrets there even though that was a lot more than a,
and a few dinners out that I spent on this thing.
I've been,
I've been hoping and wishing and fantasizing at some point about building my own
structure.
I have not done this and I've thought about it ever since I had Kevin Kelly on
the podcast,
founding editor of wired magazine,
incredible guy.
I mean really the real life world's most interesting man in so many ways know a,
an impeccable technology futurist who has an Amish beard and spends time with
the Amish.
People can listen to the episode.
It's a long story,
but I asked him what every person should do at least once in their lifetime and
he said,
build a home,
build a house.
Uh,
and I,
every time,
this is the lesson I need to relearn over and over again,
I use my hands in that capacity,
that manual labor reward.
Like you said,
it's,
it's just unbelievable.
Even yesterday I was,
I was purging,
donating a bunch of stuff that I just don't need.
I was,
I was getting rid of a bunch of stuff in the,
the,
the simple visual reward of the before and after using my hands to move a bunch
of stuff around and have that before and after.
So much more rewarding than some of the biggest things I've done on laptops or
on the web in the last few months.
I felt ashamed.
In some ways it's such a menial,
mundane set of tasks was so rewarding
to Jack.
Kevin Kelly is right and this is why as a fellow lifestyle guru,
admittedly a junior lifestyle guru,
I spend most of my time doing manual labor even though I can make infinite money
type shit into the computer and publishing it to,
you know,
the cult following.
I hardly do that at all because the not doesn't work for everybody,
but certain people get incredible satisfaction out of building because it's like
the zen aspect of it.
There's like physical and mental and problem solving.
It's like,
it's like when a human was made to do so.
Kevin is right.
In fact,
the House that I live in,
I also built,
before I built the studio,
I built as a slight exaggeration cause there was a bit of a shell.
I tore it down to like a brick shell and then rebuilt it to a different shape.
But I'm,
and every time,
like every night,
especially in the winter here when it snows,
I look up at the trees and like the snow falling on the roof that I made and the
fireplace that I put in there and the heating system that I designed,
pumping water under my floors and he how you did on my feet.
I'm like,
this is the most satisfying thing I could possibly experience.
So yeah,
you should figure out a way to build something at least like a shed quarters or
like a man cave type thing in your backyard.
And I have this thing called carpenter tourism where I go out to people in need
and build fun stuff with them and teach them how to build.
So if you ever want to do a teamwork,
um,
Tim Ferriss Studio,
then I'm,
I'm making the software now.
It would make a quite interesting story.
I could,
I could be a,
like an operating room,
uh,
assistant of sorts.
You'd be like Hammer,
Hammer,
a screwdriver,
screwdriver.
I think it'd be more of a liability otherwise,
but,
uh,
well that's how you learn though.
I'll give you the nail gun and then you'll make some mistakes and we'll bring a
welder and then you'll like explode some stuff that later you would making fine
welding lines and yeah.
You know,
I might take you up on that.
I love Colorado.
I've,
I've been spending more and more time in Colorado.
Well I was assuming we would build something at your pieces of the world where
you need a structure because you don't need to like build stuff for me.
That's not,
no,
not for you.
I was thinking about the people in need,
but maybe they don't want like some horrible,
Ferocious Picasso painting of a table where they're like,
I didn't really want some abstract,
weird thing.
Ferris,
if you could,
if you could use parallel lines and next time please.
In this case you were the person in need because you're this,
you know,
this accomplished guy who yet has,
he had a hole in your life where you haven't actually built a house yet.
So,
so I felt sorry for you.
That's all.
Alright.
I will,
I will put a bookmark in that I may take you up on it.
Here's,
here are a few questions related to consumption because I think about,
I do think about consumption of Fairmount living in San Francisco on some level
helps because you can't walk five or 10 feet without having someone to talk to
you about it or seeing billboards are seeing,
uh,
announcements and so on,
a related to some type of conservation or,
or curbing consumption.
But if you,
a few questions for you.
The first is I,
and this is related to kids,
so I don't have kids.
One of the considerations has been a concern for consumption.
So how do you reconcile kids with consumption or do you,
do you not see them as a dramatically increasing the sort of consumptive burden?
Oh yeah.
Kids are definitely a huge form of consumption.
Like if you're a rich world resident and you have a kid,
you know,
that's,
that's another hundred years of rich world lifestyle going on there.
So,
uh,
but I'm not a pure person.
I strategically in indulging fun stuff and,
and my wife and I knew we wanted to have kids and we just happen to feel that
one was the right number for us.
Um,
and I'm not judgemental of against other people,
but I,
it's just good.
It's one of the things to throw into your equation of like child raising.
Like should I have one or maybe 13?
And we're like,
well,
if if consumption of natural resources,
that is a factor,
you might not have 13,
but if it's not a factor,
you know,
no judgment from me.
And so we got one and then,
uh,
you can have probably like a four x 400% difference in the amount of consumption
you do on behalf of your child,
just depending on how you're raised them,
depending on what activities they're into and what kind of stuff you buy them
and how you train them as well.
If you train them like,
hey,
we're rich and rich people get to buy whatever they want,
then you're going to raise a super consumer and more of the richer you are.
Whereas if you teach them that there's a balance and give them a little bit of
biology and science in their upbringing,
then they're going to have a value system that prevents them from being nearly
as destructive and yet they'll probably still have more fun in the world as
well.
Is it true that you paid your son per mile written on his bike at one point?
Yeah,
we still do that.
There's just kind of a,
I like this by the way,
this is not in any way criticism,
right?
Every parent,
many of them like to find excuses to give their kids and money in order for them
to figure out how to manage it at a young age.
So I didn't want to just hand over money and like your money comes from nowhere.
So I thought that bicycling would be kind of a little income system for him.
So he has an odometer on his bike so it automatically tracks the miles and then
just give them 10 cents a mile,
which adds up pretty fast if you're an all bicycle family.
So then just give them little payouts and then we've got a spreadsheet where we
keep track of the money.
He's 11 years old by the way,
and uh,
and that earns interest.
So he has a comparison of like,
if I keep my money in the Bank of Dad,
then I'm going to earn interest.
Whereas if I spend it,
my capital decreases.
And then that interest bearing piece of like my little green employees are gone
forever.
So he still spends his money of course,
but he just knows everything's a trade off,
which is,
makes it more,
more thoughtful that you are an engineer and it's,
it seems like you have a strong,
uh,
engineered genetic through line in your family.
Has Your son tried to Ferris Bueller the odometer at any point?
Of course,
doing the opposite.
Has he figured out how to,
how to tinker with his odometer or I guess,
is he so good that perhaps you wouldn't have noticed?
Yeah,
I mean,
you never know.
He might be hooking it up to a cordless drill and spinning that front wheel.
But,
uh,
no,
I don't think,
uh,
he's not,
that's not in his personality.
Like,
uh,
he's not into really cheating on anything.
He's plus it's this kind of an abundance,
like he has more money than he can spend.
A little dude has like 1000 bucks,
then has a spreadsheet now.
And only thing he really wants to buy as is the odd video game,
which might be like 20 or $30 once every few months.
So he's pretty much retired already because the passive income and that he's
earning his,
uh,
is close to finding his video game needs.
Either that or he's got the best long con in history.
Like he's been,
he's been Connie you with as good behavior for 11 years just to,
just to tinker with this odometer,
which I don't think is the case.
But for those people who are listening,
and I'm sure you're asked this all the time,
but books on investing or personal finance,
uh,
are there any goto recommendations?
They don't have to be books.
It could be resources,
but for people who want to self educate get certainly be one of your top one or
two blog posts as well.
But uh,
if you were to pick from potentially your own stuff but also from other work
that's out there,
where would you direct people?
I think,
uh,
it depends on how interested in investing you are.
One of the key,
um,
nice things about the world,
especially the US financial system is you don't have to know much to be very
good investor.
Like you can be a top 10% investor by just buying one vanguard fund and leaving
your money.
It just putting all your extra money in there forever.
Um,
so if you're,
if that's your idea of,
of good enough,
uh,
which it should be for most people,
then you can just read any book by Jack Bogle.
John Bogle,
the founder of vanguard is one good example.
Um,
a friend of mine who's a blogger named Jim Collins wrote this book called the
simple path to wealth,
which is just sort of like,
uh,
even simpler,
more story based,
like enjoyable old man's tails,
explanation of how,
why you should invest in index funds.
And uh,
so that's another idea,
but much more important than how to invest.
As long as you don't screw up your investing,
like leave your money in a checking account or by a shifty life insurance whole
life program or whatever,
you know,
the,
uh,
the things that swindle people out of their money,
you're going to be fine in the investing side.
So the other side of that equation is a book.
And I really want to write a book myself so then I can just recommend my own.
But for now it's a really great one that's called your money or your life that
everybody's heard of.
And if you just get your get the,
whatever the latest edition of that book is,
um,
it really teaches you the philosophy that's pretty similar to mine,
which is that consumption is not really what's making you happy,
buying yourself treats.
And it's quite easy to become financially independent as soon as you modify your
spending in that way.
So huge surplus of money is on a weekly or monthly basis is the real solution to
your financial problems rather than becoming a super kick ass investor.
Yeah.
There's a book that I read,
I don't know if you've ever read this book,
it does primarily focus on
low cost index funds,
if I remember it correctly,
but uh,
by Daniel Solon,
the smartest investment book you'll ever read.
I,
I've heard of it and I had a,
I quite enjoyed that book is a little more nuanced.
Certainly anything by Bogle is,
is fantastic.
Four people who want to dig deeper.
Are there any additional books that you would recommend or that you've enjoyed
yourself?
Yeah,
if you want to get deeper,
like for example,
more into the Warren Buffett Saas side of things where you're an active
investor.
MMM.
One really interesting book that I read a few years ago is called the little
book that beats the market.
And a,
it's really a lesson on investing value investing fundamentals.
How to understand if a company actually is a good deal to buy.
And that helps put a regular,
you know,
like a sober shell around investing instead of the ridiculous speculation like
technical chart investing I think is that's kind of universally proved to be
bunk,
but people are still doing it like,
oh yeah,
the bollinger bands are wild this week I'm going to,
you know,
I see a support level at 53.5 unless something happens.
Like all that stuff is statistically it keeps being proven wrong and people keep
doing it.
So don't do that.
If you're going to be an active investor,
then get really good at understanding companies rather than technical
fluctuations.
And that's why Warren Buffet makes a lot of money above the rocket returns is
cause he's a savant and understanding business and some people genuinely are
that maybe it would probably be less than one in a thousand people.
You also do that.
He's also a savant in emotional detachment in the sense that I'd love to talk to
you a bit about stoicism and so on at some point.
But he,
he is utterly unaffected by what he would call mister market.
Right.
The ups and downs of any given company that he may have bought in the form of
shares or outright if he purchased the entire acquire the entire company.
And that type of emotional detachment is also exceptionally,
exceptionally rare.
Yeah.
And that goes without saying.
To me that's a prerequisite.
I don't have that at all.
So well,
we'll know in the sense that if,
if I'm going to be active,
it is very hard for me to be an active investor in publicly traded equities.
Uh,
for whatever reason I can do highly speculative startups and that's a
disturbingly high percentage of my portfolio because I can't balance a portfolio
with illiquid assets or it's very challenging,
certainly.
Uh,
but with,
with publicly traded equities,
if I'm trying to be active,
uh,
in any capacity,
I do very poorly emotionally with those fluctuations and I make bad decisions.
But if we're talking about something like an index,
then I'm fine.
If it's,
if it's,
if it's in,
if it's entirely hands off and I have other people or in some type of say
automated fashion with whether it's a wealth front or something else,
then I don't have any trouble with it.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's,
since I don't do active stuff anymore.
And that's,
I'm totally would agree with you on that.
In agreement,
the uh,
the book you mentioned was that by Joel Greenblatt,
the little book that beats the market.
Yeah,
that's right.
it was really interesting.
And it was a little book,
which is perfect for my short book attention span.
He is,
yeah.
Joel is,
is exceptionally,
is an exceptionally smart guy and uh,
he has a fascinating track record because he,
he can teach and he has taught in classrooms in New York,
uh,
at universities he can write.
And he's also very,
very well respected as not only a value investor,
but also in an invite and if what you would call an event based investors.
So his first book,
I think it was his first book is perhaps the most
sophisticated of them all,
which is where people can make the most mistakes.
So I think that the,
the little book that beats the market makes more sense as a,
as a first rate or maybe the,
uh,
his later book,
the big secret for the small investor,
but book with the title that is sort of blessed and cursed in the same way that
the four hour workweek just sounds so schlocky as if it's going to appear at
three in the morning on an infomercial that it's a,
but it's highly memorable.
It's been,
uh,
helpful and punishing at the same time.
He has a book called you can be a stock market genius,
which is actually really sophisticated.
I've met some of the most successful and most of,
by the way,
hedge fund managers are not successful,
but the handful I've met who have been exceptionally successful,
this book,
which was intended for novices effectively is one of their favorite books.
Uh,
so lots of,
lots of,
yeah,
lots of interesting stuff out there.
Yeah,
I'm going to check that one out for sure.
Since I like Joel Greenblatt's writing a lot and I,
I still follow.
Um,
I,
you know,
I read an investment and finance books all the time.
I just try not to recommend them too much on my blog because it's supposed to be
about lifestyle and making your life good and I don't want it to be all
esoteric,
but sure.
I do read like the Timothy Geithner book a stress test.
I read that 800 page,
um,
description of the financial crisis and I was founded pretty captivating knowing
what really happened in the background.
But for the average person,
it's not going to help them get rich and retire earlier.
So I don't talk about it too much.
Well,
on top of that,
if you want to a cautionary tale,
so for those of you out there who love,
love,
love reading,
uh,
at least if a book is captivating,
what you should get at the same time,
if you decide to get the,
you can be a stock market genius by,
uh,
Joel Greenblatt,
which is exceptional.
You should also read a book that will be a cautionary tale and it's a cautionary
tale because it,
it details the types of people that you are competing against.
If you choose to be really active in certain respects.
And it's a fantastic read.
It's more money than God and it is about the birth of the Hedge Fund model and a
number of the characters,
uh,
and most successful managers in that world.
It's a bit like a liar's poker,
but instead of bonds,
they're talking about hedge funds and it will give you a very good idea of who
you are competing against.
And when you step on you,
when you step onto the metaphorical,
uh,
golf green and you throw your money down as your participation and bet on
yourself,
uh,
the fact that tiger woods is probably two holes ahead of you,
become super,
super clear.
Uh,
and I,
I should also,
just to in in a sense reinforce what you said about index funds.
Say when I went to,
the only time I had a chance to go to the Berkshire Hathaway shareholder meeting
in Omaha,
Nebraska,
and I think they've stopped doing open Q and a with Warren Buffet and Charlie
monger.
But I actually ran in and it's,
it's insane.
I mean it is like a gigantic rock concert for investment nerds and people will
camp out overnight to try to get a good seat.
And I ran in and uh,
I was someone's guest,
which was great because I,
I was able to get in a little earlier than the entire,
uh,
the entire stadium full of folks effectively.
And I ran in and I found somebody who was volunteering or working there and I
said,
which microphone is the hardest to get to?
Cause they had microphones all throughout this,
this venue.
And that's where Udl to ask your question if they got to you and I,
I figured,
you know what,
people are going to be long winded.
Maybe the answers would be long winded,
although they very seldom are,
especially if Charlie Munger's involved.
And I need to find a Mike where I can be first or second person in line.
And so I ran up,
went through this crazy set of staircases and found this mic that was in the
middle of nowhere.
And I asked Warren Buffet if you were 30.
And uh,
I said hypothetically,
if you were 30,
you had say $500,000 to $1 million in savings.
Uh,
and there were a couple of other stipulations,
but what would you do with the money?
And he's,
and uh,
he said,
assuming you're not a professional investor,
I would put it into the s and p 500 or in an index fund and get back to work.
That was it.
That was,
that was the end of the answer.
And you know,
Charlie,
do you have anything more to add to add?
Nope.
And then onto the next question.
So,
uh,
yeah,
that's
good advice.
It is,
cause there's so much more to work on in your life.
Like if you're going to become a really good investor,
you're probably going to compromise in the areas of being a good parent or being
a good,
maintaining good physical fitness or in life like you're not really optimizing,
you're not supposed to optimize for money.
You're supposed to optimize for happiness,
which has a lot of dimensions.
So you should really like take the sort of the four hour investor,
your approach and be like,
everyone says this is good,
I'm just going to do it and I'm going to work on all the other stuff in my life
that that also needs to be addressed.
Yeah.
Well let's,
let's jump into some,
some rapid fire questions,
uh,
as I call them.
But your answers don't need to be short.
I'll just try to keep my long winded question as to a minimum.
So outside of your immediate family,
when you hear the word successful,
who's the first person who comes to mind for you?
Or who is a person who comes to mind for you and why?
Yeah.
I've racked my brain over this question because I know it's a standard,
a Ferris podcast question and I don't have a answer than anybody would recognize
because I can't judge the success of any celebrities or well known people
because success is such a balance thing and it depends on how happy you are at
home and how nice you are to the people who are close to you.
So to me,
the people in my life that I've seen,
um,
seemed to be very high and success range are a couple of friends.
These are male friends that run their own business.
They basically both fit into the same description.
So they run their own business,
they're a little bit older than me,
they're businesses,
extremely successful,
but they've scaled it right,
right back in order to be a lifestyle business and handed off a lot of
responsibility to their employees and the kind of pay them more because there's
so much surplus anyway.
And they were like,
okay,
you deal with all the junk in exchange for you never calling me on the weekends.
So both these friends work pretty minimal,
like 10 to 20 hours a week.
And yet somehow they're businesses keep doing better because of this hands off
approach.
So they're making even more money.
Um,
but yet they have a fairly mustache in lifestyle.
And this is probably because I,
I met these guys through the blog and then they,
they both have kids and they've really,
really good relationships with their,
their children.
They're semi adult children and their wife and basically just really good shape,
physical shape.
They do a lot of adventures.
They always say yes,
if I invite them to do something,
they're like,
oh yeah,
that's sure we'll,
we'll fly over and meet you in that random spot for some mountain biking or
whatever.
So they've come,
they've managed to combine all of these dimensions of what most people want in a
kind of a carefree way.
And,
and they're not overly focused on any one of them,
which allows them to be extremely fun people to be around.
So that's my definition of success and that's what I kind of hope for for
myself.
By the time I'm like 50 years old with a pretty old kid.
We're,
we're on the flip side,
we talked about what some of the critics get wrong.
What perhaps media sometimes misinterpret,
where do weird your fans get it wrong?
What are the most common mistakes that your readers make or misinterpretations?
Uh,
when,
when did they get the message wrong?
That's pretty rare.
I find it's a,
it's pretty there.
I ride a lot of stuff,
right?
So anybody who reads a lot,
they'll see all the little nuances and bits in what I try to express as a
philosophy.
But for those of them,
um,
those readers who don't have other details,
a lot of people assume that I'm very,
you know,
like I would be mad at them if I ever found out that they bought something
luxurious.
Like,
Oh,
don't tell Mr Money Mustache,
I bought this $2,000 mountain bike because I really love bikes.
But you know,
everything else is good.
And like,
I don't,
I don't judge people to nearly the standards that they think I judge them too.
So,
and,
uh,
the other thing is it's the same for people who don't know my real life.
They often assume that it's pretty spartan.
And then I'm always penny pinching.
And this goes back to the same answer with the New Yorker article too,
but,
um,
I'm,
I'm really,
I'm really in favor of,
of celebrating and decadence and,
and feeling like stuff is luxurious.
So,
uh,
so I'm really not as minimalist as people people think I am.
I'm really maximalist in the fun department.
Besides these studio,
what are some of those luxuries?
And we could tie that into,
uh,
let's limit it to purchases that have most positively impacted your life or that
you just love because they're so damn fun for you.
What,
what does,
what are some of those things?
Um,
while some of them,
some of it is vacations.
So since,
um,
since retiring from real jobs,
my wife and I have had a nice tradition of going somewhere semi-tropical every
winter for a good long period.
Most windows at least sometimes the school schedule messes it up a bit,
but,
but yeah,
for a month or more we'll often go and so we spend some money on these vacations
and we'll rent a nice house on a beach.
I'm like in Florida or Hawaii or Costa Rica or whatever.
So vacations,
um,
most of the money goes to rent basically like Vrvo type stuff.
AIRBNB is one example of indulgences that I still have a lot of warm memories
from.
And I really like knowing that I can do that at any time.
So even when I'm not on vacation right now,
in January,
and uh,
sometimes if the cold weather blows in,
I think,
man,
I could just press a few buttons on this computer and just fly right out to
anybody's Vrvo and be there within like a day or two.
And,
uh,
just having that freedom is a form of luxury in itself.
And then I can go out and shovel some snow and be happy about it.
And,
uh,
yeah,
the other purchases,
um,
nothing's really expensive,
but when I built out the current house,
the main house rather than the studio,
I was feeling pretty rich at the time.
So I,
I went a bit high end on some of this stuff.
Like I have this really gorgeous high efficiency wood burning wood stove,
fireplace thing that brings me pleasure every day even though it's more
expensive than a,
you know,
then then just a basic fireplace and the window is in my house for example,
are very kind of these fancy windows that cost about five times more than than
it would have cost if I'd gone bare bones.
So it's usually stuff related to home,
vacation and food.
You know,
we've been known to go out for Sushi a bit more than a person in debt should go
into Sushi.
So we take advantage of our non debt status.
That's the,
it's really not too much though.
Yeah.
Do you have any favorite documentaries or movies?
My favorite,
uh,
I'm actually got a huge,
huge,
less of documentaries that I've been meaning to watch.
Many of them collected from the,
from the guests on your,
um,
tools of titans book.
But the one that I did watch and enjoy is actually a series rather than
documentary,
but the,
um,
the cosmos that the remake of plasma,
the older grass Dyson.
Yeah.
I love Neil degrasse Tyson and uh,
I love his awkward but scientific way.
And the topics he covered in those in those episodes were like so stunning and
it was a great education for my son who is very,
very into science himself.
Um,
so that's kind of like,
that's the documentary that stands out in my mind.
The great,
the most interesting thing in the last five years.
Anyway.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's a fantastic series.
I've been hoping in meaning to have Neil on the podcast.
We've had I guess some,
some indirect email exchanges.
So if anybody's good buddies with Neil,
give him a poke and let them know that it's totally tapped him on the podcast.
If you were to give a Ted talk on something that you are not known for,
what would you give it on?
So any,
any kind of pet obsession or something your lesser known for maybe your die hard
fans who've read every single line of everything you've ever written would have
heard of it.
But,
uh,
yeah,
if you had to get think I do have an answer.
Yeah.
So if you define the thing that I'm known for as the early retirement,
Mr money mustache stuff,
then the other topic that I'm super passionate about is,
is energy.
And I'm like the world energy balance and solar power and how the humans,
how humans consume it and how we can basically fix our energy consumption
related to climate change and all this stuff.
So I'd probably write one up about that and explain how we're at this insanely
close tipping point where fossil fuels are just about to be economically
unfeasible,
even without regulations and stuff.
And,
uh,
I think that can make a good title Ted talk because a lot of people are,
you need to popularize the ideas and right now they're kind of dry and numbers
based,
like you're talking about terra jewels and kilograms CO2 and all this stuff and
there's a lot more fun and emotion in that topic if you,
if you package it right.
So I think that'd be a good talk.
Yeah.
What is your,
like what I've been curious about,
I know you've written about this before,
but when you are,
if you,
if you were to think of when you and your,
when you were in your best physical shape in the last five years,
what did the exercise regimen look like?
Cause I saw a photograph of you,
I want to say squatting outside at an outdoor squat rack.
Am I making that up?
Yeah,
that was my most recent blog posts.
Okay.
Starting to get a little old now.
But yeah.
So
if you think back to when you were in the best shape and you can define that any
way you like what,
what did your exercise regimen look like?
Yeah,
it's,
I might be in,
in some ways and some of the best shape I'm in my life right now.
And that is just a pretty casual program,
but with really efficient barbell exercises combined with just a whole bunch of
walking and biking construction.
So,
um,
so the,
the barbell stuff is just squats,
dead lifts,
clean and press a little bit of benching and stuff with kettlebells and
dumbbells and generally using weights that I can just barely lift five times.
And the total expenditure of per week is only in that the order of like an hour
or two.
So I'm not like a a gym rat.
I'm so that right now I'm pretty happy with the way my body's working,
especially for a 41 year old or whatever am.
Um,
but the,
the strong,
I was slightly stronger when I was in my twenties and it was basically the same
stuff,
but just going to the gym for a longer period and training,
it was really just more hours put in.
And that's when I,
I've probably had my record,
um,
weightlifting in certain exercises.
Do you lead a quote or any quotes that you live your life by or think of often?
Um,
I don't really think in quotes too often.
Maybe with the exception of use it or lose it seems to come up at least a couple
times a day.
I'd say that's often enough to to be a response.
Yeah.
It's so short and a and thus memorable.
You don't have to be all flowery,
poetic to appreciate,
lose,
use it or lose it.
But I think it's because,
uh,
in the current stage of my life,
being over 40 and then having some family members with,
you know,
some people have died in my family and had serious health problems like in the
extended family.
And uh,
it's really made me a more aware of mortality and how stuff doesn't
automatically stay in perfect condition.
And even if even if it does stay in perfect condition,
you're unlikely to live forever unless some really,
really big medical stuff changes before I turned a hundred.
So anyway,
I use it or lose it is the philosophy like brain,
body skills,
friendships,
relationships.
Just do everything that you want to be good at as often as you can.
And uh,
don't fool yourself that you're going to keep being able to do this stuff unless
you continue doing it regularly in the,
and uh,
I don't know which,
okay.
Label to use here,
but in the safe frugality or low costs living world,
what is the worst advice or what is bad advice that you hear given often?
I think the biggest issue with that I have with a lot of this,
a mainstream financial advice is that there they make you think of saving as a
negative,
that kind of a negative obligation.
They're like,
yeah,
we know it's feels a lot better to buy yourself treats,
but come on and like,
if you can just squeeze out 5% or even 10%,
then you're,
you're doing okay.
Just do that every week and make a budget and all this stuff.
And uh,
so you're,
you're training people to think that saving is bad and you want to minimize it.
Whereas I think it's a win win and most of our spending is,
is a sign of weakness.
And it's a bunch of stuff that we do to compensate for our weaknesses because we
couldn't solve the problem in a smarter way.
Like as we talked about earlier,
is possible to walk or bike to work,
which is a physical and mental when,
and it just happens to cost a lot less.
So I encourage people to radically reshape their entire lifestyle to be
optimized and all these dimensions and sure you happen to save 50 to 75% of your
income as a,
as a byproduct.
But the only reason that's a win is because your life is better as well.
And normal financial advice is it doesn't really address the life stuff.
And you know,
you see a lot of these totally out of shape,
business guru people trying to sell life insurance at the same time as they're
giving you financial advice and they're not really,
you know,
they're not really in it for making people's lives better.
I think that's where,
that's where it falls flat.
Yeah,
for sure.
And
Yeah,
it's uh,
it's important I think certainly in,
in almost every area,
but in the,
the world of financial planning and advice to ensure that the person giving the
advice has done what they're suggesting
or has some practice putting their words into action because otherwise,
uh,
they haven't stress test their ideas,
or at the very worst they're hypocrite and they're doing the opposite of them.
Uh,
okay.
Are there any failures that come to mind,
which are a favorite failures of yours in the sense that they ended up sowing
the seeds of a later success?
Does anything like that come to mind for you?
Yeah,
I have a pretty pretty serious one that I call,
I have an article called Mr money.
Mustache is big mistake and it's right after I retired in 2005,
I kind of faded in to a my first dream retirement job,
which was to start a custom house building company where I was going to make
these beautiful ecofriendly houses or did actually we started making these
houses and um,
and the problem was it was way,
way more stressful than,
than what I wanted for retirement job.
And I just had this new baby boy at the same time and suddenly I had all these
obligations and like a construction loan to build this thing.
And I was doing marketing and working late and wrangling all these cats
together,
like the contractors to help out building the places.
And uh,
it wasn't really retirement at all.
And on top of that,
we did it right in time for the housing crisis.
So like we sold our first house into the 2006 boom market for housing,
but then by the time the second one was done as 2007 and everything was slowing
down and then starting to drop like a rock and then I was stuck with this
beautiful ready to sell house and nobody wanted to buy it for any kind of
reasonable sum.
So that was kind of soiled.
The fund spoiled the fund of my first three years of retirement is running this
company.
Um,
at the same time though,
going through hardship was,
was really good for me.
I had to do a lot of hard stuff that I wouldn't have done.
And that's how I learned a lot of my,
um,
best carpentry stuff.
You know,
the skills that I'm most skilled,
I'm most proud of is,
uh,
like as I've always messed around with woodworking since I was a little kid,
but by being forced into production on these expensive modernist houses where
everything has to be perfect,
it really trained me a lot and I enjoy those skills now.
So the combination of shittiness and skills and then,
then we shut this company down.
And since then I've been truly retired and had so much more fun looking back and
like,
wow,
I'm sure glad I'm not doing that anymore.
So it lost a bunch of money.
You know,
some of my retirement savings went up in smoke initially.
Um,
and then I was started to be a bit more worried about money.
That was a big part of it cause I was like,
oh my hard earned savings.
And if I could go back and change that,
I would probably still do it.
But I would train myself to be just so much more relaxed about and be like,
dude,
don't worry.
You're going to have so much fun after this and you're not going to run out of
money,
so just have good time with your business.
Um,
even if even if it fails,
what was the process like of shutting it down in the sense that,
was there particular dinner or conversation or bike ride or a moment when you
decided to start the process of shutting it down and how did that,
what did that look like?
Well it was pretty,
it was pretty quick cause I bought these two vacant lots and kind of a premium
new urbanist neighborhood with my business partner and the,
and the company.
And then we started building the first one and it was the aforementioned stress
was high and was like,
Oh shit,
what have I gotten myself into?
Okay,
let's just get these things done and then be done with it.
So then I got the first one done and then like,
Woo,
that was great.
You know,
big success.
It sold for more than we were even asking for it.
And then the second one,
um,
God more and more stressful.
And I already knew before I even started that second one that I wanted to shut
down the business afterwards.
It just got drawn out longer.
And then we got into like renting it out,
but then the tenants turned out to be horrible and they had these like scam
artists move in that we didn't realize were scam artists.
And they were like,
Oh yeah,
we've got,
we just sent you the rent that's in your mailbox,
check your mailbox,
click in the hangup and all these like little tricks.
And the guy had like this,
you know,
fancy like brand new corvette that he had bought and he had to hide it in the
garage cause the repo man would take it back if he ever saw it outside.
So all he could do is like pull it out,
Polish it and rev it and then put it back in the garage.
And these people were just really messed up and I happen to get tangled in their
web for awhile and we had to use the,
uh,
the full on eviction with like sheriff come into the door to get them out of my
place.
And,
uh,
so yeah,
there was some education in there.
It sounds like a headache.
Uh,
what did it feel like when was it finally done?
Shut down completely.
And what did,
what did that day feel like?
Um,
I'd say it was shut down.
One of the biggest problems with this is that the relationship between me and my
friend who started in business partner,
it does,
it just soured and it became pretty bad by the end.
And we had totally different views about work and money and dividing stuff up.
So we finally got him out of there by,
I basically had to buy out the company.
I had to put,
like I'd lost all this money and I had to put like a final $460,000 into the
company to pay off this mortgage that was on the house.
I'm just to kick him off the,
the deed,
the property deed so that I could have control of it.
So that day was kind of like,
you know,
we're like frowning at each other,
over the lawyer's table or whatever.
And then since then that that lifted the weight off of me and then everything
was so much better.
And then for awhile I rented out the house to great tenants and I hadn't in that
situation,
I was just using the rent for kind of our grocery money because that house was a
fairly big portion of our retirement savings,
uh,
income at the time.
And then more recently,
I think just less than two years ago,
I,
the market in our area here in Colorado started to boom again.
So I just sold it for a nice high price.
And then now I've been super relaxed and then that's kind of like another wave.
And it really taught me a lot about happiness because this negativity in my
life,
or at least I was choosing to perceive it negatively,
it was washed away and then suddenly I was happier than I could've ever imagined
being,
um,
because I'd gone through this somewhat hellish situation and then remove the
negative.
Yeah.
Which,
uh,
is,
is such a valuable question.
I,
the question to ask before purchase that that alone will return a hundred x the
effort of scheduling and doing this interview.
For me,
that question is this removing a negative from my life?
That's such a powerful reframe because I think that is so true.
Uh,
and so,
so incredibly useful,
but did the next,
which is going to be completely flipping that on its head.
And this is not one of my usual questions,
but I'm so curious to know how you'll answer this.
Okay.
If you had had to spend,
you were given $100,000 and they said you have to spend this,
you have to buy something or some things you cannot donate,
donate it to charity.
Uh,
you cannot stick it into an investment vehicle.
You have to spend it.
Okay.
And it has to be on you,
your family or your close friends.
But it can't be charitable in the sense that you're say parent paying for the
college tuition of your friends' kids and so on.
Nothing like that.
How,
how would you spend that?
What would you do with that?
That was my answer.
You just took my answer.
I knew because I felt like it was coming cause I could pay off somebody's
mortgage.
There's still one family member in my close family that has a mortgage.
But,
but yeah,
we want,
we want to consume here.
Um,
can I have more than a hundred thousand?
Sure,
sure.
No,
it's not limited.
It's not limited.
This is just,
let's just say that you took a step into bizarro land where everything was what
it wasn't and suddenly you are the Anti Mustache,
right?
Yeah.
And what w what would you do?
Well,
the thing is,
this might actually be somewhat realistic because I still consider every day,
you know,
is there something I could spend money on,
um,
that would be worth it.
It's still an open question.
You don't want to be ideological about this stuff.
But,
so one thing I've been interested in maybe buying and if I was forced to,
I would do it quickly,
is a,
is a building,
I kind of want to own a commercial building on our towns,
little historic main street.
This town I live in,
Longmont,
Colorado is kind of one of these over a hundred year old things where it's all
historic with big trees and the narrow main street with a tall brick buildings
on it.
So I could buy one of those.
And then set up,
you know,
some kind of fun community space in there where we,
we play music and we have parties and we rented out and do some teaching too.
Cause I like to,
uh,
do a bit of volunteer math and science teaching two,
two kids kind of advanced stuff that they don't get in the normal school.
So I could have like professor mustaches,
School of Science in my downtown building so that that'd be kind of a fun use of
money.
Yeah.
This is more of course a,
a metaphorical question,
but if you could have one gigantic billboard anywhere with anything on it,
um,
what would it say,
you know,
short message or image that like to
impart to the world?
Right.
I'm picturing this in a u s metropolis because that's kind of where I'm focusing
my efforts right now.
So I think I would say,
I think it would say walk or maybe you'd say just walk something that people can
really understand quickly.
I like without getting,
yeah,
back to our original thoughts.
It's the under,
it's the best prescription medication in the world and yet it's so under done so
far.
So that's my billboard.
Yeah.
It's,
we've made as a species,
so many evolutionary trade offs to be able to walk with a level head.
Unlike Sam pig that doesn't have a nuchal ligaments and their heads bobble over
the place,
like we've evolved to be able to,
as it would seem a survival imperative,
walk very long distances.
And I just feel like humans are generally better humans and lesson erotic when
they walk a lot.
Uh,
at least that's true for me.
I'll speak for myself.
Uh,
I'm like 10% less neurotic,
which is a win for me.
Billboard could say,
just walk,
you've paid a high evolutionary price for this ability and let's not squander
it.
What,
what are,
what are one of your biggest challenges right now?
How do you plan to think about it or face it?
I think my biggest challenge is the over satisfied rat in a cage syndrome where,
uh,
it's a fine line between being too satisfied.
You are with your life,
with your life and not doing enough.
So that you feel like a bit of a,
a Weenie at the end of the day for squandering one of the few days of your life,
uh,
versus overdrive and yourself to be like,
Whoa,
I've got to accomplish more.
You know,
I have all these gifts and,
and great situations and I have to make the most of it.
And taking either of those two extremes,
um,
can lead to a pretty unsatisfying life.
And this often,
I often compare myself actually because um,
this is a little bit weird,
but to you as Tim Ferris,
cause I've read some of your books and I see some of your self reflection in
there where you have some of these battles.
You're like,
well should I be perfectionist or should I relax?
And I have a lot of these same questions to myself.
And one of the differences is that I,
I chose to have a kid and I focus a lot of energy on that,
which by definition subtracts a lot of the other stuff I could do.
Like why am I not running my own kind of Tesla type company or whatever.
So that's my challenge is,
is trying to walk the line and have the,
at the end of each day be satisfied that I've created the right balance of like
stress and accomplishment versus lazy decadents which is part of the fun of
really being early retired is that you generally can like just smoke a bowl and
have some fun with your friends on a Wednesday and like sleep and it does not
matter and you still are going to have all the money that you need no matter
what.
So,
and that's still,
yeah,
I still have trouble,
I've been a little bit on the lazy side in the last couple of weeks because of
family conditions here at home.
And so I'm,
I'm craving to get back to work on something hard.
How will you,
how,
how do you think you'll explore that in the coming year?
Uh,
testing that balance or,
or trying different things to try to find it or maybe it's,
maybe it's a matter of just oscillating between the Poles and that's how you
achieve balance.
It's not like you're never,
it's not like you're ever 50,
50 for a long period of time.
You just oscillate between the Poles.
I don't know.
But how are you thinking about that?
Because I'm also thinking about the same thing in 2017.
Yeah,
well it's a continuing series of experiments.
Um,
and it's always changing.
Like I've been at this for a long time.
It's been 11 years since I had a real job and I've done a lot of hard stuff and
then a medium amount of laziness in this time.
So I keep trying stuff to see if I enjoy it.
So like last August for example,
I wanted to see if I enjoyed the ted talk,
kind of public speaking,
and I did a whole bunch of traveling around that as well.
And I found it was a bit too much.
Like I enjoyed the actual stuff that I did,
but I was craving being at home.
And then that's made me realize that most of my joy comes when I'm actually
creating something.
And this is why I'm less travel oriented than other people because I can't
really create,
well I'm traveling,
so I need to do a certain amount of like nitty gritty construction and design
and just hanging out and having an unplanned,
spontaneous people coming over for a party or a barbecue or whatever.
So I need this village life.
Few.
Imagine a primitive man living in a village where he spends half the time
hunting some of the time,
like building stuff and some of the time reveling around the fire.
That's kind of my core of happiness and when I get too much into lifestyle guru
activities like,
oh,
I'm going to publish more articles or get this book done quickly,
or say yes to all these interviews so I can have more and more fans and page
views.
Those things sound actually,
they sound dumb when I say it like that,
but when you look at the,
you know,
when you look at news headlines about yourself,
you're like,
that's successful.
Or you look at page views or money,
you go,
yeah,
that's success,
but it's actually good.
Kind of the least happy thing that I do,
it's the least satisfaction bringing.
So I have to balance that with,
um,
with these much more village type of activities.
But if I die,
if I totally neglect the internet world,
then I'll feel like I'm letting the world down because you can actually create
good positive change that way that you could never do just in your own village.
Right.
What have you changed your mind on in the last safe handful of years?
Is there anything that you've done an about face on in any way or modified
substantially
and your thinking?
Um,
there've been a few little things,
like what type of eating as healthy.
I kind of switched to the,
uh,
the high fat,
low carb eating on a whim after reading some books.
And uh,
I'm really,
really happy with that.
Whereas before,
when I was a teenager,
I was the ultimate low fat because I read all these bodybuilding magazines back
then and they were always telling you like,
Oh yeah,
10 grams of fat.
It would be way too much to have and other stuff.
So that was a change in a little way.
MMM.
The biggest change I've had though is more in my understanding of happiness.
Uh,
I thought that happiness came from,
from maximum achievement and maximum wealth.
And as I got into experimenting with those things sounds too much like my other
answer,
but I learned much more about the balance that's required for happiness.
So it's changed my goals for the rest of my life is that there's a lot more to
happiness than just being maxed out in one dimension.
So I only have a few questions left.
I'm having a lot of fun.
I mean,
we could keep going for many,
many hours,
but uh,
do you have any ask or request of my audience?
Uh,
any experiment you'd like them to do,
exercise,
anything.
It could really be anything but uh,
any,
any parting thoughts before I ask you where people can find out more about you
and so on?
Right.
Well
if you are new to this stuff that I talk about,
then I would suggest and if any of that,
if anything that I am advocating sounds crazy.
Like,
for example,
not using a car to get your groceries or not using car to get to work,
then try it and think of the idea of voluntary hardship to put this at phrase
into your mind and then see where you can apply it through the day,
and then you're like,
hey,
that looks hard.
I think I'm going to do it instead of,
I'm going to try to avoid it.
And voluntary hardship is that the gateway drug to the rest of mustache aneurysm
and thus being able to save 75% of your silicon valley income while everyone
else is still broke.
So yeah,
find some things that are hard,
even if it's just skipping the elevator and taking the stairs up to the 15th
floor or whatever.
MMM.
Just if the other people are not doing it,
then that's probably a sign that it's something that you should do and then just
record your results,
see how much better it makes you feel,
and then just keep pushing yourself a bit further.
I would echo that,
spin it slightly differently.
It's not the,
these are complimentary viewpoints.
But even if people listening,
those folks out there listening,
if you do not want to focus on saving,
even if that is not the objective per se,
voluntary hardship is a fantastic way to short circuit hedonic adaptation where
you need more and more and more,
almost like an opiate to satisfy your need for x.
And I would highly recommend everybody read a letter.
You can find it in the public domain online.
I can also find it in tools of titans in a slightly edited fashion,
but on festivals and fasting.
It's letter 13 from Seneca,
uh,
Seneca,
the younger two,
Lou killies,
the moral letters to looky loose on festivals and fasting.
And it talks about setting aside a few days per month,
let's say two experienced voluntary hardship in different ways.
And it is,
it is such a fascinating psychological trick in,
in many respects with all sorts of beneficial side effects like cutting down on
expenses that I think allows you to realize it as possible to recalibrate
yourself to experience greater happiness and wellbeing without simply adding
more and more and more.
And more and more,
whether that's page views,
money,
fancy shit,
you don't need it or otherwise.
Uh,
as I've,
I definitely want to second that notion.
Uh,
Pete work in people find out more about you and uh,
you've,
you've written a lot.
Where should they,
where should they start also?
So we're going to find you on social or they say hi,
where can they read your stuff and where should they start?
If,
if,
if there,
they're just opening the doors to your writing.
Okay.
I'm a big fan of old fashioned websites,
so there's always Mr money,
mustache.com and you'll see start here button on there and that takes you kind
of to an introductory article.
And then the design of the website to the limited extent that it has a design is
just to poke around and follow links to other links and or you can start at the
beginning and read all the 400 plus articles,
uh,
dating back to 2012 or 2011.
And uh,
yeah,
that's how most people do it.
And then you can read it.
Yeah.
If you get really into the rabbit hole,
then there's a forum where like all these users discuss their intimate problems
with each other and it's got like tens of thousands of members that spend all
day on there and uh,
or you can just for keeping it really light,
you can just go to Twitter and look up Mr. Money Mustache and uh,
let's say,
hey,
I enjoyed the podcast.
Perfect.
Thank you so much for the time.
I really appreciate you taking the time and to everybody listening.
As always you can find links to everything we discussed,
books and otherwise at the show notes,
which is for this episode and every other episode,
four hour workweek.com forward slash podcast all spelled out for our work
week.com forward slash podcast and as always,
until next time,
thank you for listening.
Hey guys,
this Tim,
again,
just a few
more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email from me every Friday?
That provides a little more soul of fun before the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I share the coolest things I've found or that
I've been pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the uh,
the world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance.
And it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to a four hour work week.com that's four hour work week.com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you'll get the very next one.
And if you sign up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought to you by wealth front.
Wealth Front is the future of financial advice.
They become incredibly popular among my friends in silicon valley and across the
country because they provide the same high end financial advice that the best
private wealth managers deliver to the ultra wealthy.
But for any account size and at a fraction of the cost,
for instance,
they monitor your portfolio every day across more than it does an asset classes
to look for opportunities to rebalance or harvest tax losses.
Now,
would you do the same?
Are you doing the same?
Probably not.
And the powers in the software wealth front now manages more than $4 billion in
assets,
which is up from around 2.5 billion.
When they started advertising on this podcast,
they're growing incredibly quickly.
Unlike old fashioned private wealth managers,
wealth front is powered by innovative technology,
making it the most tax efficient,
low cost,
hassle free way to invest.
They don't have bloated sales teams or retail locations,
so they can deliver all of this sophisticated financial advice and the services
at a fraction of the cost of a traditional financial advisor.
So at the very least,
go to wealthfront.com forward slash Tim and take their free risk assessment
survey.
It only takes a couple of minutes and Wealthfront.
We'll recommend a personalized portfolio of investments.
In other words,
they'll tell you exactly where they would put your money,
so even if you don't use their service,
you have a huge leg up and you have additional information for making good
decisions.
They use investment theory to automate good financial behavior and decisions
that people typically don't make,
but should so go to wealthfront.com forward slash Tim to get your first 15 k
managed for free or just to get more details,
check out wealthfront.com forward slash Tim this episode is brought to you by
Varidesk and I'm actually standing at my own Veritas from right now recording
this.
You've probably heard of research that shows have sitting all day is terrible
for your health.
Sitting is the new smoking,
et Cetera,
but standing all day isn't necessarily the answer for everyone.
Sometimes you just want to sit down.
And that's true for me as well as the middle ground is varidesk varidesks height
adjustable standing desk solutions allow you to stand when you want to sit,
when you need to.
And as an example,
I had this set to the lower position.
This is a large model and it took me clickety clack two seconds to raise this
thing up and it feels like it has hydraulics effectively because I didn't have
to use any muscle to do it.
Varidesks converts your existing desk.
For instance,
if you want to get a tabletop virgin,
which you could put on it,
which is very,
very cool or cubicle and do a sit stand workstation and allows you to raise your
desk from a seated to standing position in just seconds,
ships fully assembled so there's no Allen wrenches screwdrivers required.
Pull it out of the box,
put it on your desk.
In the case with this particular model,
no installation or fascinating required.
There are bunch of different options.
The models start at just $175 so check out [inaudible] dot com to see what model
might be the right fit for you.
And my assistant now has one,
I have one.
We've really,
really been very happy with it.
So if you're not sure if it's right for you,
that's fine.
They have a 30 day risk free guarantee,
which lets you try it in your own home or office.
And if you decide it's still not for you,
you want to get rid of it,
they arrange to pick it up,
no hassle.
So check it out,
veer odesk.com that's a v a r I desk.com.